oh my god
whoa i go everywhere with my bulletproof
vest you have to run there's not enough
running it's such a dumb move that felt
pointed but you're right
david's the scream queen obviously i
answered with my heart i am slumping
ghost's face
i am folding him like an omelet we're
taking this part too seriously hi
buzzfeed my name is mason gooding and i
play chad my name is jasmine savoy brown
and i play mindy hi my name is marley
shelton and i play sheriff judy hicks i
am dylan minnette and i play sun wes
hicks
my name is jack quaid and i play richie
my name is melisa varrera and i play sam
hi i'm sonia and i play liv hi i'm mikey
and i play amber i'm courtney cox and i
play gale weathers i'm nev campbell and
i play sydney prescott i'm david
arquette and i play dewey riley
and today we're gonna find out if we
would survive a screen movie
probably not
if your friends were to typecast you in
a horror movie who would you be the
final girl the scream queen the nerd who
explains everything the loner who is
misunderstood the skeptic the older and
wiser mentor david's the scream queen
obviously i read these questions a
little earlier with my cousin and she
told me that i would be the older and
wiser mentor i don't want to be the
older and wiser mentor but i i'm going
to decide
i probably would be but i think that i
also explain everything i'm going to go
with older wiser
owner who's misunderstood just because i
like that dude oh i think that's i think
that's probably appropriate well you're
definitely the final girl i'm the scream
fan actually or the scream queen i mean
it's a toss-up right um i feel like my
friends would typecast me as the nerd
who explains everything which is funny
because that's that's
what you play that is what i play i was
typecast in scream yes i think i'm going
to go scream queen maybe the skeptic i'd
be the loner i think honestly i think
that mason and i are both the nerds that
explain everything skeptic you would
definitely be the skeptic voice you'd be
like no why am i going in the room why
would i he's the nerd or jackson or jack
might be the final girl mason you could
also be the older and wiser men yeah no
i disagree that's very sweet i disagree
what did you choose in the end i chose
the nerd
i chose scream queen ring ring you're
getting a phone call but you don't
recognize the number what do you do
let it go to voicemail pick up and hang
up you hate the sound of a ringing phone
send a text instead asking who it is
pick up and ask who it is turn off your
phone you don't hear the phone because
you don't know where it is i know that
one i'm the last one i don't know where
my phone is ever you have to let it go
to voicemail just in general all the
time for safety
there you go i i definitely would let it
go to voicemail i'm gonna let it go to
voicemail kind of guys
if i see a phone number i recognize
you're never speaking to me i know but
those spam calls like oftentimes i
answer them and then i hang up like true
like hello and then i hang up but then i
i also like lose my phone quite often i
feel like i get so many spam calls and
unknown calls and i get really annoyed
but i still answer every time i never
know where my phone is i'm always like
in a mad chase looking for my phone
before i leave the house you know what
it is you need to get a colorful phone
case i promise you like change my life i
feel like i would definitely let it go
to voicemail i me too i feel like that's
the smartest answer mason i i know how
many things that you lose so i feel like
you're definitely you don't hear the
phone because you don't know where it is
that felt pointed but you're right jack
you see i feel as if you would pick up
because you wanted to be respectful for
whoever took the time to call you even
if it were a telemarketer i'm the person
who picks up when like a person is
calling me to spam me and i'm like
either yell at them or i play along and
jasmine that's why you're the scream
queen pick
a fallen scream character why is he
yelling
why are you dracula
i don't know
billy loomis cottonweary casey becker
maureen evans randy meeks jennifer jolie
maureen evans wait wait wait what just
pick one that's mario
pick one pick one and why is it maureen
evans oh i picked casey don't do that
i'm gonna go with casey becker going
randy i know i should go ready too i
love reading did you pick one yeah who
how do i keep jumping around no no you
don't get to we're taking this far too
seriously all right
i'm picking jada just because tina's
family okay i gotta go with randy meeks
i think everyone was very sad when he
bit the bullet and uh screamed too so
that's that's my guy i'm going with
randy i'm gonna go with billy because
he's a psycho but
he's also really cute in the first film
i had a crush on her so i'm gonna pick
billy i think i'm gonna go with jennifer
jolie only because she was a character
that really got under my skin i've gotta
go casey becker drew barrymore one of
the most iconic scenes of all time like
yeah i am going to pick jennifer jolie
because i just loved that character he's
so funny great character i love parker
posey i'm going with cotton weary
misunderstood and you actually you
actually kind of you could be his son i
could be a weary okay what would you do
if the killer was in your house hide in
a closet run outside and flag down help
call 9-1-1 call the friend who always
picks up to help stay and fight play
dead play dead no not enough people do
that well no how do you play dead
they just decided to come in and you
would already just immediately die run
outside and flag down help i'm going to
call 9-1-1 because if i run outside i'll
probably get hit by a car i'm not i'm
gonna go with that i'm running you have
to run there's not enough running i feel
like it'd be convenient if you were
already dead when they walk in the house
so i don't like why would you play dead
100
i'm gonna go call 9-1-1 yeah i feel like
if you play dead like what they can't
chase you like what are they gonna do
they're not gonna mess with you so like
i'm gonna do that i would be scared that
the killer would make sure i was dead
like stab me again to make sure i had
like a knife i would like play dad and
like have a knife there
i always think of playing dead i think
it's so dumb it's such a dumb move but i
always think that that's a possible
scenario to do of course of course you
do i'm very convincing play dead go play
dad melissa
there it is that would work until you
asked the killer if you were doing a
convincing performance i feel like i
would play dead too to be honest so
you'd play that and just be like huh we
have to let ourselves get stabbed once
and go oh i'm dying yeah definitely say
i'm dying as you're dying that's really
putting a lot of stake in living through
one knife stab
that's tough i picked uh call the friend
who always picks up they already cut the
phone line the the police are not coming
let's just call someone you trust frame
one i pressed stay and fight i am
slumping ghost's face
i am folding him like an omelette which
scream twist shocked you the most billy
loomis admitting to killing sydney's mom
and scream mrs loomis being the
mastermind in scream too
roman bridger being maureen's long-lost
son sydney's brother in scream three
billy loomis and stumper being the
original killers in scream
sydney wearing the bulletproof vest and
scream 3 jill roberts sydney's cousin
being the reboot killer in scream 4. i'm
going to say billy loomis admitting to
killing sydney's mom and scream because
we didn't know
how shocking all this was by the next
one you kind of knew could be anything
shocking i'm gonna go with roman bridger
because it was kind of out of nowhere
yeah that was like the weirdest yes
we're going billy and stu being the
killers that was a very amazing original
twist i'm hitting that too billy loomis
and stewmacher i feel like i have to go
with billy loomis admitting to killing
sydney's mom and scream because that
just
came out of nowhere it's big it's like
an insult to injury and by the way yeah
i killed your mom that's how he said it
too i went with uh uh jill roberts
sydney's cousin being the reboot killer
in uh scream four i
i don't know i i think i knew the least
about that one and rewatching all of
them and i that one really surprised me
i think i'm gonna go with the roman
bridger you know sydney's brother and
scramjoy
certainly sydney wearing the bulletproof
vest and screaming yeah i'm pretty good
i gotta be honest i didn't i don't know
where she found the time to get a
bulletproof vest i go everywhere with my
bulletproof vest lastly for funsies pick
an iconic gayle weathers look
the iconic long bob and the first one
the iconic chunky red highlights and the
second one or thanks babe thanks
i gotta go with the fringe
iconic chunky red highlights
i mean i think we're all gonna pick the
same one the whispy friend i mean the
wispy fringe right for me i choose the
ugly i mean
i chose the fringe the bangs
[Music]
i died ah i died too oops you died i am
so sorry but you were the first to go
well congrats to me because i survived
same here welcome to the team
i died oh my god i died too i was the
first to go whoa i died but i didn't die
first i mean i died but i didn't see it
coming so at least i didn't have to live
through the terror i guess that's the
best way to die i fought a good fight
but unfortunately the killer got me
before you could i could get them and
it's just a gif of uh of randy i died
but it says at least i had the most fun
you fight for your friends i fought for
my friends and died that's where i get
my strength as my friends despite all
the stabs shots punches and shoves you
survive until the very end after all
someone has to live to tell the tale i
answered with my heart okay i wasn't
trying to win i survived
i died but i died first you died first
i'm sorry but you were the first to go
see we knew david would be the survivor
i like it
you